hello bloom house fans bloom house blue
house page how you doing blue house calm
that's what we're looking at its Greg
here from the real rejects John as you
know from blue house and the real
rejects is helping us with this event as
we interview a little Q&A session with
Jesse Garcia from the show from dusk
till dawn on the El Rey Network how are
you Jeff Simon
Jesse question number one mm-hmm how
many questions can I ask you as many as
you like oh yes I'm actually a big fan
of the show from dusty when I first met
Jesse I had only seen the first couple
of episodes one thing that I wasn't
expecting was just how much they were
gonna evolve your character throughout
the show did you know when you got the
part that they were gonna have this huge
like evolution with Ranger Gonzalez I
actually didn't really know a whole lot
about it when I auditioned for it I
wasn't really sure closed for series
regular or not okay because the
characters completely new to the sword
of the world it wasn't in there before
they made him irma Graz you know protege
and after you want to say on season you
see like all this backstory that has to
do this dad and Mike's stuff from young
or old like he was always so cool that
were talkin for it was like in September
like late September of 2013
I guess 2013 have you already seen the
movie oh yeah yeah yeah it's every tons
of times I've seen the dark and happy
made the movie
oh really yeah and yeah I've always been
a huge fan of Robert I did the first
audition I met with Robert and we did
the scene a few times and I'm have a
super-short at the tanks I just got done
doing his Miller
maybe it was a military move it's called
jarhead - you were a jarhead - yeah
straight-to-video baby - yeah oh man
I like the first jarhead yeah you I have
not seen yet I really like the first
jarhead yeah so I met with Robert we did
the first audition it was September that
year I remember because the almond
Awards are the same day and like a bunch
of us I remember seeing go over there
and you've ever seen DJ walk out and a
couple other people - had you known
anyone from the guy I knew what woman I
did a movie together seven or eight
years ago called days of breath and
never came out okay I just never came at
it so good they think I just said it
because I was about to lie and say oh
yeah now it's a digital paperweight
somewhere
I wish it would come out there was it
was a pretty pretty decent movie so I'm
mad with Robert and then I didn't hear
anything about like oh man I didn't get
it audition um he had we held the
auditions at the four seasons here in LA
so a month goes by I didn't hear
anything about unexpected thing and then
I get a call from my manager was
Halloween weekend of 2013 I remember my
another kind of fun trivia fact that I
am also a certified yoga instructor are
you really yeah yeah do you see each
yoga occasionally like I have in a while
because I've been pretty busy with the
show and then other things I'm
remodeling remodeling a house and a yoga
instructor yeah why you know I'm
multi-talented and just a regular human
being
whoa annie has a heart yeah so
so I I get a call from a manager saying
hey you have a callback for desk I'm
like but the series and she goes yeah
it's like all right cool when is
inch-thick tomorrow says I got a call on
Thursday go tomorrow 10:30 more night
goes there any news new pages like yeah
there's a bunch of new pages oh my god
oh [ __ ] bunch of your pages and a bunch
of Halloween parties to go to that night
I'm like I can't miss my Halloween party
it's like I went to all Halloween
parties I go inside dance for 20 minutes
and go out in an alley study for 20
minutes and back and forth all night
wow really so I had my side with me and
um I came over what I dressed as but I
was like outside reading it was like
where he goes steady for not just for a
while next day comes and I go in and
there's like 20 people ahead of me and I
call all my buddies I know almost
everybody they're going for the audition
and marry for news casting director she
really worked it made quite a bit and
she was like my angel on all she really
worked for me hard shoutouts at the cast
injury I'm just casting yeah and then I
did my audition and I was like I'm gonna
wear home I mean I was really cool I am
I'm over take her some chocolates and
some like a bottle of wine or something
as a thank you you do this audition in
front of rob Rodriguez not robber was an
Austin at the time okay so this is a
callback wasn't in front of Robert okay
so this was like taped and this was
taped yeah captain sent to him and then
I go home I make her some chocolates and
I'm doing bottle one taking it and it's
like my last night last weekend a yoga
teacher training I'm gonna go there and
then go to class and then let's finish
my night I'm on my way there but manager
calls a cave Robert wants to Skype with
you and thirty minutes can you Skype
with him I'm like yeah yeah for sure and
I'm gonna do it the casting offices
issues being nervous at all um maybe
little maybe looks like okay it's like
yeah I gotta do it again you know I mean
it's like it's a lot of pressure so I
get to the casting office I scheduled
Robert for 20 30 minutes in him and I do
Tim and I just do a scene together we're
just cool enough for me
you know Amelia I'm skyping with Robert
Rodriguez and he's reading the scenes
back and forth with me and we're talking
about the chef he liked looking at you
so I get off of the Skype session with
him and like that itself was awesome
you're nice cuz you know he's one of my
heroes were my filmmaking heroes I go if
I don't get it
it would be super bummer but there's
absolutely not nothing else I could have
done like I did my best I could do my
audition
mm-hmm if I don't get it then it's just
not meant to be so I go to my yoga class
which was my last one last to week two
of the cycle turn off my phone and this
is by 6:30 7 o'clock and I don't check
my phone again to like 10 o'clock that
night so I get my phone and it's blank
and I'm getting it ready turn off is
like I got a bunch of missed calls and
tanks in the car like it's tapped on one
of my managers you can why are you my
god what's going on I look at my emails
like 15 minutes ago
Desmond but a big thread from a manager
and my agent a sec oh they're checking
your quote their offerings in the car
what that's crazy that's nice dude yeah
so is this the first pilot you'd ever
booked
yeah Wow yeah pilot was straight to
series Oh straight to series yeah oh
[ __ ] Rika's ease they control the
network yeah which is it's his sizzle
baby that was Friday night Saturday
morning I get a call from robbers came
in and welcome to the show and you know
we're excited to have you
so Saturday I prepare everything that
didn't I need to prepare in LA so that I
can go to Austin the very next day Wow
Sunday so I find a whole life just
changed completely just flipped Wow and
they climb a fly out on Sunday and I
finally have a chance to read the first
episode and I'm reading it exhausted
because I'm like all these are the
things are taking care of my Center for
my dog and remember this you're going
back for that's gonna happen land around
six o'clock or so go straight to
troublemaker which is awesome because
it's trouble maker studios yeah and I
walk in is just like spike it stuff
everything like this prop pieces oh my
god this is so cool we're basically
planning my costumes for the entire
season because we have to shoot out Don
Johnson's entire season in the first
week yeah he's all flashbacks yeah he's
all flashbacks except for the first but
he only had he only had a week span to
shoot okay shot all of his stuff so we
just shot all his coverage and later we
had to go back
shoot some of mine without him and it's
robbery biggest what was it was the
first scene you shot hey well the very
first thing I shot was the diner scene
with Donna really yeah so that one
really cool yeah the one with him and I
are talking about seeing family and the
baptism and all that yeah I remember
yeah yeah you remember better an idea um
but it was like trial by fire and like
my mom
Brian Bentley who's the first ad he's
like he's still laughs but maybe he came
in a trouble maker eyes all wide and
like yeah dude my eyes are still out why
this is so cool so you said like a fan
when you go over this totally man I'm
still every time I walk in it's like I'm
a fan like i still find new set pieces
and did you feel nervous at all about
being a new character for now you feel
it would have been more pressure if you
were doing a character it would have
been more pressure to be like one of the
established characters because then you
have to live up to that character yeah
to some degree the guys are completely
different from even he's like although
when the women are completely different
from totally you know from the original
people but I didn't really have that
pressure the pressure I did have was to
create an audience to like me yeah you
know I mean it took I think until
episode six of the first seasons where I
kind of felt really felt like another
torture scene man well I'm getting
toward you and it was beating me up in
Hazzard because little vampire monkeys
kicking my back vampire monkeys is
anything in the show yeah yeah think so
I felt I felt like that was my first
kind of like oh okay so like then they
said going okay this is what Jesse's
good at and this is a town okay and it
took me a while to kind of get you know
you watch these movies like oh I'd be
cool to color do that look like but
until you're in it you know it took me a
while to understand the genre and I was
gonna sit yeah and see how to do these
certain looks and it's cuz its own if
its own animal
you know I mean yeah cuz I I was
watching this I don't worry we're in the
second season I was commenting about how
it looks like you have a lot of fun
doing it you seem very comfortable in
the action genre yeah and you're right
halfway through the first season is when
they let your character like get outside
the law yes or doing his own thing a lot
more yeah and I feel like I
I feel like I could sell it more like
the dark kind of like vulnerable
emotional come yeah heavy stuff when
that scene came up and I really felt
like I did good work oh my god cool yeah
finally got a good feel like it I was
fitting in because it was for me it was
like trying to fit into a world that was
already established you know what I mean
yeah you know and then Carlos gave me a
call that the showrunners came in with a
great word today and you know a couple
people mentioned it like all cool music
finally feel like I'm fitting in a
little bit but everyone they're so
supportive you know I mean like that the
whole cast and everyone's that you know
anyone needs to run lines or okay I got
the day before who do you see have the
most fun with on side everyone man you
don't have like a favorite I have a
favorite um Brandon - Brandon is awesome
he's like one of the nicest guys you'll
ever miss your man he's such a sweet guy
super smart I admired him a lot that
he's a badass martial artist
oh is it I was you know I was watching
the show thinking I wonder if he really
does work oh yeah he's a beast okay
that's cool he does um
this third season your way to see some
the stuff that he's doing like everyone
took it up a huge notch for all the
action and nice da more cool toys and
the new season I might do my diva have
some fun a lot of fun do I keep those
toys ever no as I love the one that I'm
Brandon where you have the things
strapped to his chest and then those are
cool yeah you have like that someone was
badass moments of the show yeah you're
not in the fourth episode until the very
end when you say that's no way to treat
family yeah and I remember like cuz I
was showing it to someone that perfectly
I was a really badass it's so funny yeah
because they really eject you out a lot
more they talked about how like Ranger
Gonzalez is a lot of toys now like all
these weapons hit around the house and
everything yeah
what's cool I can in his world in
Roberts world that they you know all of
a sudden guns come out of No
was he getting all these guys pulling
knives at my sleeves and I think it's
like that's just the world you know what
I mean is he like an active so he is
like a really active developer of the
show yeah yeah he's like everything goes
through him really okay so you know
there's definitely you know Carlos was
the showrunner but everything like
Robert definitely has a heavy hand in
anything it says you know that's his
baby what's it like working with Don
Johnson he was really cool man like I at
the beginning the first thing we did was
like five and a half pages long it got
cut down in the final edit and because I
got cast so fast it was five and half
pages of dialogue I'm just sitting back
to sport nothing nothing nothing to to
kind of distract and do anything and
able to cut around I didn't know one
word and I'm like and I'm going holy
crap I hope Don Johnson's not off book
and then we do the first first rehearsal
and he knows his mind
pretty much got the whole script I'm
like holy crap and they were like the
crew the crew was so nice to me like I'm
studying and I'm doing like I'm cheating
and doing things I would never do like
I'm hiding with sides on the side right
here and and actually actually got me a
teleprompter I'm like yes I will take a
teleprompter because they offered it to
me like did we know he got cast very
last seconds if you need any help just
let us know
Wow yeah it was it was trial by fire me
I don't I don't get fired this first
week I'm okay I'm okay for at least the
season but he was awesome man he's like
he's a legend you would basically look
you would look at a scene wanting all
right cool got it that's awesome it's
been a big part of the Rodriguez world -
all right I'm like Tarantino world team
Anna - yeah that's [ __ ] do you learn
anything from work because he how you
you told me how you like to you work on
filming stuff to yourself mm-hmm
did you get to learn or anything like
hands-on throughout these past two
seasons there's no rubber our radius
sometimes directs yeah and there's
nothing like fede alvarez oh no I mean I
just saw his don't breathe movie like it
was awesome yeah you see it I haven't
seen it that's awesome yeah what's it
like working with like
these kind of guys I'm the great man
everyone comes in it's got a whole new
energy what would you say is unique
about like they're directing style I
mean each one of them like Eduardo
Sanchez comes in and the thing about TV
directing is like everyone comes in and
has her own really kind of unique stamp
of what they like to do and it's a lot
of fun you know I mean I'm like Eagle
Adelson who did two episodes this season
he's done tons of TV and I actually
worked with him and CSMA I mean 10 years
ago when he came in he's like dude
what's up he came up as a DP and I was
like a really established and what well
respected director so he had a really
heavy hand and the camera were amazing
and his net and that episode was gonna
look amazing and they're all gonna look
really great but everyone kind of has
their own little niche Joe Menendez came
in and he had kind of has his own style
and the season one he he did kind of
like a bunch of cool shots like they
were throwbacks old 70s movies and old
seventies action films would you ever
want to direct an episode I totally want
to yeah yeah I tell him every every week
so hopefully by you know season 10 don't
let me direct an episode the effects on
that show mm-hmm is most of it like
practical are you feeling a lot this
year especially yeah there's a lot of
practical we try to do as much practical
as we can that's like my favorite one of
my favorite parts of the show there's a
lot of practical but the CG is just
unbelievable you know I mean you see
some shows and some TV shows that you
just don't put a lot of whole lot of
money into the CG effects yeah if you
watch any of it pretty firm from season
one on it's like it's seamless you can't
really tell you can't tell one us yeah
we're gonna mean consumption even movies
you can tell when a CGI there's CGI team
they're just so so good they're so good
even when I saw the trailer like the new
guy that has I keep forgetting the name
of his character he has a cowboy hat and
like he has his weird fucked-up face and
I remember just having like him having
blue dots on his face and like they turn
it into that I'm like oh my god it looks
so good oh I'm like season three yeah
there's a character or where it's
actually not words yeah you see it's in
the trailer is there's a
I have to slow that down I guess yeah no
I'm not giving anything away because I
definitely saw in one of the clips like
just knowing you're a part or something
like yeah I go away tonight there's a
set piece for oh my god way to you the
end of season 3 did you unbelievable the
stuff that they built I walked in like
holy [ __ ]
this is unreal unreal the set pieces
that they built and if you look I said
styrofoam like some of this is like yeah
and plaster and S&M but the artists that
we have the crew
I was one of things I loved I loved
about the show was that especially we
came to the vampire look mmm was that
they didn't like they honor the original
vampire look yeah like these are not
good-looking yeah I remember sitting
with Asia season one going [ __ ] I'm
having like she's beautiful you know I
mean yeah and to have her just sitting
like we they can't just take that [ __ ]
off between 10 yeah it takes hours to
put it on under than ours and take it
off and just sit there and talk to her
with her Culebra face it's like it's
there [ __ ] [ __ ] with you a little bit
you know yeah I'm like people walking
around with half a monster head because
some of its able to come off and some of
its not seeing people eat through straws
and super delicate it was never scary on
set then ah kind of hard to be huh yeah
now I mean it's like you everyone's
super nice yeah everyone everyone wants
to be part of a run forever be [ __ ]
so just like a blast word it's like it's
just fun um you have to do training for
any of the show mmm I haven't liked the
guns and oh yeah they would they go
through with us and our weapons
specialists or like they
show us everything and make sure we're
comfortable with everything they take
gun control and gun safety very
seriously yeah yeah JJ that's all calm
there so there's some times where it's
like it's clearly either oh yeah like
they try to get as much as we can to do
the actors to do all the stunts and all
the fighting will do it because we like
that stuff yeah I mean we get our butts
kicked and we get hurt every now and
then but no yeah it looks like you're
having a blast yeah there's so much fun
we have there's some really fun fights
so many you say like it amps up like the
fun Oh totally yeah we're all stuck we
have some really cool guest stars coming
in Hertz Tom Savini isn't it that's
pretty [ __ ] yeah he's who is sweetest
guy to you man yeah kiss stories are
awesome
yes it's like a guy who is so cool
stories let's sit down and talk with
enemies such as such a cool guy sweet as
can be Marquez RR okay yeah yeah he's um
he's a martial artist he's been in a
bunch of movies he was in this third one
of the undisputed movies with with Scott
Atkins okay you know he is yeah yeah so
he did one of them and he's such a sweet
guy too
you were telling me that you do too
Jitsu yeah does that ever come in handy
in any of these fighting I'm sure yeah I
mean like you just use a kind of a
ground game yeah I even noticed like the
like wood punches even mm-hmm like to
throw a good punch it seemed seems like
you learned how to throw like a solid
good punch yeah well I mean lucky for me
I kind of trained some boxing some like
various things okay yeah I remember the
specific genres like hook someone yeah I
was like like a real like okay yeah but
I stun guys they're they really work
with us and make sure that everyone's
safe I mean I could throw a punch from
from the John over there and make it
look like I hit him how would you say
the cast members were different from
including yourself don't you say
everyone's like different from their
characters DJ cotrona be sexy as [ __ ] in
real life yeah no he's super handsome
super handsome I mean exactly yeah
smart well-read amazing hair yeah just
got just got perfectly immaculate hair
yeah just the wrong I'm get just a
perfect I counted Zane Zane Holtz is a
monster like he's just likes he's a
sweet guy like he's just super funny
goofy guy he's super strikes me someone
who might be goofy goofy and funny and
he's really smart
you know you know but when I'm work with
and I'm set to it he always has a really
great direction like hasn't his ideas
are always really good oh so he's like
really creative he's very creative very
nice and he's a brown belt in jujitsu so
he's a monster dude like I roll with him
and he just kills me like uses like come
this is Hannah my poor in and I'm just
like doing this I started doing jujitsu
Madsen super smart beautiful her
character the seasons were really cool
she used to do a lot of cool action
stuff to get to play a lot same thing
with Scott
I'm sorry Brandon he played Scott if
they ever larger characters turn into a
vampire would you do it in the show yeah
no I wants to throw that makeup
yes wrong this whatsoever give you a
specific storyline where you can't be so
yeah that's cool I thought maybe I told
him like I don't want a fantasy scene I
don't want to dreams do not makes it
through that makeup baby I'm like I'm
gonna make a chair going barely put
makeup on as it is like we got put blood
on you Mike
notice what are you in blood
Oh the first season like the last yeah
course Racine or like bodies oh yeah
like blood covers I saw the fun the the
costume that I wore for it was like
episode 7 8 9 10 last first season okay
covering blood covered in blood so to
keep continuity they didn't they
couldn't wash the pants right I would
literally pour baby powder in my pants
so that the pants would stick to me is
like this awesome yeah
the shirts they can wash every now and
then but it was like it was like just
basically crusted over and like oh my oh
my god this smell terrible by now and it
was sticky and at least at one point
they go oh we can just do the non sticky
stuff like apple doesn't do this two
episodes ago still just sticking around
your neck sticking to your neck is is
wonderful - oh yeah yeah how could I
forget
Ava and Jake Busey hilarious and super
smart is he be creepy at all in real
life no no anything I've seen him in
accretion me out he's just funny I feel
like he's kind of like the leti levity
of kind of like he brings a lot of humor
to it you know me Nikita
he loves this subject his character
loves his subject so much he's so
passionate about it it's [ __ ]
hilarious actually that really tickled
me part way through the first season
when he really went when they run into
with the twister he just lays down a
lecture yeah yeah tell his guys of
course it's funny like we would get him
like we would all study with each other
like whenever we have scenes together
specially the whole super long scenes
like that
yes his dialogue I wouldn't want his
character either because he says he's
fair lots of exposition and talking
about you know Aztecas Mesoamerican
stuff I'm like you not want those words
coming out now line s you're so very
good like what like all the cop lingo
that all different codes and numbers
whatever the hell you gotta speak like
you sometimes you have to give lengthy
like dialogue first the first season so
that the the cop jargon and number
this and that there was one particular
speech that I did probably five or six
times the one where I'm like my hands
are up my hands are bloody and it
started before all the [ __ ] goes down in
there yeah and little shop numbers all
over the place I said like my painting
mind's monologues about that big you
know I mean that's just like I remember
I said that big impatient yeah there's a
lot of stuff in there I had to do a
bunch of repairs I'd give me one we're
taking we're taking I finally did it and
all these numbers and all the numbers
tied into each other and also what I'll
do is I'll look around the room and I'll
tie a certain word into something I see
so that's where oh cool I mean so like
I'll know something that's cool the word
some is some word it's associated with
the coffee pot and over here this
pumpkin and I look over it's something
to do with this like when I look around
I have little tricks to make me memorize
like I know I look here first there then
I look up there and I look over there so
I have words that tie into each one so I
know that what we're the key word that
comes in next yeah so tiny little tricks
yeah you got some complicated lingo
there's a lingo complicated especially
in the first season well yours is you're
like really competent yeah yeah I hope
they really hope to put a blooper reel
together this season because really oh
yeah I've never seen a blueprint I want
to see a blooper reel of this season
because it was so much like art bloopers
are hilarious
hey Joe favorite movies lebombo guys
watch all the Disney cartoons like all
the Disney movies like Dumbo and like
you know all of them I didn't really
like horror when I was growing up so I
grew up Jobos witness did you know this
about me I read it on Wikipedia yeah so
I grew up and Joe was witness and like
oh so wasn't really allowed to watch any
horror stuff or anything with like
ghosts or anything including like
Ghostbusters cartoons
even scooby-doo because I go Stan it's
like I'm watching that stuff so I kind
of like we got brainwashed a little bit
into thinking you know Korra was bad
then I then I fell in love with it when
I you know got my own mind back I don't
know Ghostbusters even when I was a kid
chocolate factory gremlins me and ete
all the classics Goonies Goonies of
course under your favorite Rodriguez
films um dusk mariachi the trilogy of
course desperado desperat was amazing um
spy kids movies are super fun I'm gonna
name all the Shane was awesome yeah Sin
City was great you know who I would love
to see appear from dusk till dawn
no Gibson yeah be fun I think it'd be
really fun very super fun because you
know a machete kills yeah that's my
connection there yeah you talk to the
writers yeah if I had any pool I would I
think you do yeah more pool than you
realize your favorite Freddy moment was
or or favorite piece of the party take
off your shirt and you go into a lake
yeah that's pretty cool okay so there's
that moment so that is a fun fun fact it
was snowing that day and it was about
thirty thirty degrees that day reason I
was supposed to be crossing like the
river into Mexico and it was just so
cold and I can I go you guys got one
take listen mr. Menendez actually
directing okay and then there you can't
get one more Miguel yeah
it was cloudy and like they put in a
steed digitally and would not have
guessed it was snowing that's snowing it
was cloudy like and they made it work
I keep imagining your character showing
up on a horse one day it could happen I
really think Ranger Gonzalez could use a
horse yeah I like all your scenes oh you
might know my favorite moment is when
you show up and you say that's no way to
treat family this is like your delivery
on it was like perfect and I think
that's signified a big moment for your
character new as like establishing your
role in the show right have how like
important your of how much of the hero
you are tell me they love you and we're
not talking I love loves you and wants
to know if you can tell her anything
about Steph Kate in season three
I cannot there are a couple of them